Hello and welcome, everyone.
This is Active Inference Lab Gueststream
number 16.2.
It is June 11th, 2022.
We're here with Mark Solms.
This is the second part
in our discussion.
We had an awesome part one today.
We are going to have a recap
on some of the points
that were addressed in the first part.
In 16.1.
And then we're going to head
into some unexplored territory
So, Mark, thanks so much for joining
for these sessions.
And please take it away.
Thanks, Daniel.
Glad to be here again.
I was just
testing out, sharing my screen
a minutes ago, and it seems as if
I'm incapable of showing you my face
and sharing my screen at the same time.
So take a good look at me.
You're not going to see me for a while.
Here comes my screen. Please, God,
there we are.
Great.
And here comes my pointer.
There we are.
And here's my title.
The emphasis is on physiological
and philosophical considerations
rather than computational ones.
So I'll start with a brief recap.
I made a few claims,
and I didn't get to the end of this list,
so I will just remind you
what those claims were.
And then I will pause when I get to
the point that we stopped at lost time,
which was here.
That effort
is an extended form of homeostasis.
I started with the claim,
which really is the main claim
of my of my presentation.
It is that affect feeling
is the foundational form of consciousness
and that it is intrinsically conscious.
I quoted Freud, who more than anyone else
introduced the notion into mental science
that mental processes
are not intrinsically conscious,
that much of our cognitive processing
goes on unconsciously.
And even he made this point,
the point that I'm making,
which in his words was that
it is surely of the essence
of an emotion
that we should be aware of it.
That is, that it should become known
to consciousness.
Thus, the possibility
of the attribute of unconsciousness
would be completely excluded as emotions,
feelings and ethics are concerned.
And I emphasize the word feelings
because there's a whole lot of reasons
why some people claim
that they all such things as unconscious
emotions and unconscious affects.
So just to be absolutely clear
what I'm talking about here.
I'm talking about feeling.
And you can't have
an unconscious feeling.
In other words, you can't have a feeling
that you don't feel
So whatever might be meant by unconscious
emotions and unconscious affects
and that they can't apply to feelings,
they can't be unconscious feelings.
But that might
sound like a semantic point,
just a matter of words
that you can't have the feeling
that you don't feel that's an oxymoron.
So I then went on to set out
various reasons, empirical ones,
why the claim that feelings
are intrinsically conscious
also has a solid empirical basis.
I I drew attention to this discovery
that was made in 1949 already
that the brain mechanisms
for consciousness itself.
In other words, what wakes us up
in the morning
and puts us to sleep at night,
the sort of switching on and off
of the lights of consciousness
that this is the business
of the reticular
activating system,
the reticular activating system
is the brain system
for arousing consciousness,
for activating cortical processes
and rendering them conscious.
I also mentioned the Perry Aqueduct
to Gray
which plays a and, and also it also plays
a crucial part in all of this
together
with the reticular activating system.
But I'll come back to that later.
For now, let's just focus
on the reticular activating system
to give you a sense of what I mean by
how these structures are they.
Their intrinsic function is the switching
on of the lights of consciousness
I, I pointed out
that you can make a lesion
or you can suffer a lesion as small
as two cubic millimeters in size.
In the para brachial complex
of the reticular activating system.
In other words, a lesion
the size of a match head.
And that is enough in human beings
reliably
to obliterate consciousness entirely.
So I was saying
let's look at these structures
and if we wanting to understand
something of the intrinsic consciousness
generating mechanisms of the
brain and I made the point
that if the cortex,
which is where we normally shine
the light in terms
of looking for the neural correlates
of consciousness, if the cortex were
the seat of consciousness, then there's
an easily testable prediction,
which is that if you have a case
in which there is no cortex,
then the patient should not be conscious.
Not so.
Therefore, I showed you one such case
and this is one
representative example of its type
that shows a patient born with no cortex.
The condition is called dren.
And carefully here
you see in an MRI scan of the brain
that where cortex should be
there is just cerebrospinal fluid.
And you see that
a brain stem is perfectly intact.
So on the view that this brain stem area
is where the consciousness is generated,
that it doesn't require cortex
this is a critical case
on the brain stem view.
She should be conscious on the cortical
view.
She should not.
And yet she is and she is conscious.
As you can see.
She wakes up in the morning,
she goes to sleep at night
in the sense that the lights are on.
But much more interestingly,
she's not merely blankly awake.
She hurt her.
Her her wakefulness has a content
and the quality
and the quality that I'm talking about
is affective quality.
You see how she responds to her
baby brother being placed on her lap?
She responds with some form of pleasure.
And so there's there's a content
to this mental state
and a quality to this mental state
that she's displaying
Why that's important is
because when we first learned in 1949
that the reticular
activating system is prereq
was it for all consciousness that there's
no such thing as cortical consciousness
without brainstem arousal of the cortex,
that we had the view
that the cortex provides the qualities
and the contents of consciousness
and the reticular activating system.
Mary merely provides the the,
the quantitative dimension,
the sort of level of consciousness.
So it's as if this was a power supply
like a television
set needs to be plugged into the wall.
The reticular activating system
is the prerequisite sort
of booting up of the system,
but the television set itself
the cortex where the contents
and qualities of consciousness
are processed could still be claimed
to be the seat of consciousness.
And the reticular activating system
merely as a
and as a power source.
This is why it was important
to point out that this child
is not only conscious
in some blank sense of wakefulness
without content and quality,
but rather that she displays efforts.
She's emotionally responsive to her baby
brother being placed on the lap
just as this child, who also has no
cortex, is emotionally responsive.
Yeah, you can see she's responding
with pleasure
to a stimulus,
and this is quite generally the case
for these children just beyond MCAS.
Summary of his observations.
In many, many, many such children,
they express pleasure,
they smile, they laugh,
they show aversion and fussing.
By arching their backs and crying.
Their faces are animated
by these emotional states.
They build up sequences, they smile,
they giggle, they laugh, they show
great excitement.
ET cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So I've
highlighted all of those words to show
that these two cases that I just showed
you with no cortex, they are conscious
and they are responsive,
and in particular,
they are emotionally responsive.
And on this I base the claim
that these children
do have a quality,
that they do have a consciousness.
And this consciousness does
have a quality and it does have content.
Many people look perplexed
as to how this could happen,
since they have no cortex.
How can they respond
to things like their baby
brother's been placed in their laps?
And so I just inserted this slide.
I don't think I showed it last time,
just to point out that our sensory
and organs he has the example is the eye.
Same applies to two to the skin
and two to hearing and taste as well.
The the
optic nerve that
projects to the lateral genic Nicollet
and from there to the visual cortex.
But not only to the visual cortex,
it also projects subcortical
to the superior calculi
of the midbrain of the brainstem,
which is immediately
adjacent to the peri aqueduct
gray, which I said earlier
I was going to mention again.
So these children receive information
in the brainstem
which is not conscious,
it's not cognitively conscious perception
that conscious perception
is generated in the cortex,
but unconscious sensory
information goes into the brainstem
where it is responded to consciously
by the emotional structures
that are the main focus
of what I'm talking to you about now.
And of course many of you
and like many of my colleagues,
will reasonably say, well,
how do you know that there's something
it's like to be those children?
These might just be reflexes or instincts
and these
these might be the equivalent,
these kids of philosophical zombies.
In other words,
they look as if they're conscious,
they behave as if they're conscious.
But we can't know that
they're actually conscious.
And so last time I tried to address
this, this objection
by drawing attention
to what happens in cases
who lose great swathes of their cortex
and are able because they haven't
lost all of their cortex,
they are able to describe to us
what it's like to be them.
This is one way
of getting around the objection
that because these kids have no cortex
and therefore can't declare
their conscious states,
we can't be sure that they have
conscious states.
So I focused first of all on the case
who has a massive lesion
of the prefrontal cortex.
The reason I did
that is because this is a favorite
part of the
cortex for those who claim
the cortex is the seat of consciousness,
like the global work space theorists,
they say it all comes together
in the prefrontal lobes.
All of this information
that's processed in the posterior
cortices is re represented
or accessed in the global workspace.
And this this is where the center
in being the subject of the mind
comes about.
And I pointed out last time
that if that were the case,
then where again,
we have a falsifiable prediction,
a patient who has no prefrontal cortex
like this patient of mine,
a patient w he has no prefrontal cortex,
but he has a sliver of language cortex.
He if, if his sentient being
was was contingent upon
the integrity of prefrontal cortex,
he should not have sentient being.
And so I showed you what it's like I talk
to him about what it's like to be him.
He claims to be consciously
aware of his thoughts.
I ask him to imagine something
for me to imagine
a two dogs and a chicken,
to see them in his mind's eye.
Then I asked him to count the legs.
I thought this would be a reasonable test
of whether he's actually got
conscious mental imagery.
And please note the person
I'm talking to refers to himself as I am.
So he seems to think that he exists
as a safety and being and I ask him
how many legs they are in total
if you have two dogs and one chicken.
And to my disappointment, he said eight.
And when I questioned his answer,
he answered.
He pointed out that in his mind side
the dogs at the chicken.
And so I thought that was
maybe not a great joke,
but it certainly suggested
that there was somebody at home.
And I made the point
last time that these patients,
generally patients
with massive frontal lesions
and that this tendency to make Purell
jokes is considered to be a rather common
part of the frontal lobe syndrome
or the frontal lobe personality
and this is part of the bigger story
that I mentioned last time, which is that
these patients are generally quite
emotionally disinhibited
and why that's important is because,
remember, what we are considering
here is the question
as to whether the feelings
that you saw in those patients
those kids with no cortex
where whether
those feelings could be generated
in the brain stem.
And the claim of the of
of cortical centric theorists
like Joe Ledoux, for example,
is that the feelings literally come about
when they are registered to re
represented or labeled or even named.
Some people claim that it's only once you
are able to re represent this
this these subcortical survival circuits
in a declarative consciousness in
prefrontal lobes, that this is literally
what brings the feeling about.
And I think it's quite
interesting that these patients
who have no prefrontal cortex
and don't have a dearth of feeling,
which is what you would expect
if the machinery that brings feelings
about is absent,
then they shouldn't
be able to have feelings.
But in fact what is generally accepted
is these patients have an excess
of feelings and
there's the
disinhibited emotionality
in these patients
I made much the same argument about
the the other major
cortical area that is associated
with the symptom and self,
and that is the insular cortex.
Of course, this is associated
above all with the work of Bud Craig.
But has been very widely accepted
that the feeling self comes about when
when one's the state of one's
intercept of a body is,
is, is re represented in insula cortex.
And so again,
we have the falsifiable prediction.
If you take a case who has no insula
cortex like this patient of DiMaggio's,
then there should be no
and self at present.
And I showed you this interview
where Damasio speaks to him
about his sense of self
and the patient is perfectly adamant
that he exists as a self.
He speaks about
himself as I, I, you know,
and it ends.
This interview ends with Damasio
saying You're aware that I'm aware.
And the patient be says, I'm aware
that you're aware that I'm aware,
you know, or, and,
and this patient just like my patient w
is not deficient in emotionality.
In fact, all the basic emotions
are present, including
both bodily affects and emotional affects
and sensory affects.
And not only that, he's
also a little too emotional.
And this is a little disinhibited
in his emotionality.
And this is what we quite generally
see with patients with insula lesion.
So again, it's very hard to sustain
the argument that the self actually comes
into being in the cortex
now of course,
those two cases,
those examples of the kinds
patients with massive frontal
cortical lesions, passive patients
with massive internal lesions,
of course they are just examples.
But the point is the point I'm making now
is that the there's lots of cortex
left in those cases.
So the argument is, well, you know,
maybe this
the and subject is generated
in the remainder of their cortex.
And it's a bit of a it's a bit
of a circular argument because remember,
the children do have no cortex
and we're told, well, how do we know that
that they're conscious, they can't report
their conscious states are
then gave these two outstanding examples
looking at the areas of cortex
that are most bound up
with with a sentence subjectivity
according to cortical theories
of consciousness and these patients
seem to have intact
a sentence subjectivity.
But now I'm told
well you know the remainder of the cortex
might be what's
what's generating the consciousness.
So we can't use only lesion methods.
There's no way out of that impasse.
And so I then showed you last time
evidence of a different kind
and I showed you
what happens if you stimulate reticular
activating system nuclei and there again,
there's a there's an easily
tested prediction.
The prediction is that
if these brain stem nuclei
that would kill activating system
in Perry Aqueduct, as I'm claiming,
if these are the structures
that generate consciousness and feeling,
then stimuli lation of these structures
should stimulate conscious feelings.
And I showed you that he has a case
who had a steep
brain stimulator placed into this
substantia nigra this this part of her
reticular activating system
and within 5 seconds
it's it generated
it produced a profound depression.
The patient was actually suicidal.
She didn't want to live anymore.
This is a patient
with no psychiatric history.
The electorate was placed
in her brain stem
for the treatment of Parkinson's disease
and and stimulated the wrong nucleus.
And that's how this came about.
90 seconds
after the stimulator was switched off,
the depressed feeling disappeared
and the patient generously agreed
to allow for further stimulation
in the reticular activating system.
And all of it.
And it was only when
that particular nucleus was stimulated
that that she fell into the depression.
So this is the kind of evidence
and remember, again, I'm just giving
you examples.
You can
stimulate intense affective states
by stimulating reticular
activating nuclei and peri aqueduct gray,
you get the greatest intensity
and the greatest variety of ethics
from stimulating there
and you get nothing of the kind
from stimulating cortex.
So this is a different line of evidence
suggesting that feelings
on actually generated
in the upper brainstem.
And then I showed you
another line of evidence
that was positron
emission tomography and of people
in intense affective states
and here you see
research participants
in states of sadness
here, of anger
here, of happiness here of fear.
And in all instances yes,
the activation is in the brainstem
and the circuits arising from it,
the subcortical circuits arising from it.
That's what we see
the cortex is
by contrast, largely deactivated.
So this is a further line of evidence
that the,
you know,
an entirely different line of evidence.
Remember,
with a lesion evidence that we got
deep brain stimulation evidence
here, we've got positron emission imaging
evidence that
the part of the brain
that's generating the feelings
is the part of the brain
that switches on the lights.
And this is why I'm claiming
that the basic
the foundational form of consciousness
and this prerequisite form is affect.
Affect
is the elemental form of consciousness.
A further line of evidence
is pharmacologic called manipulations.
If you tinker with the neural modulators
that are sourced in these reticular
activating nuclei
like for example, noradrenaline
or serotonin
or dopamine, all of which the source
delivered to your activating system.
Right.
Serotonin is, of course, regularly
pharmacologically manipulated
for the treatment of depression,
dopamine for the treatment of psychosis,
noradrenaline
for the treatment of anxiety
and noradrenaline is sourced in locus
release complex
serotonin in the RAF nuclei, dopamine
at least the one
that's important for psychosis
in the ventral tegmental area.
All of these are parts of the reticular
activating system.
If, if all that this system did
was switch
on blank wakefulness,
it might be of interest to anesthetists.
But in fact it's it,
it is the main target
of the drugs of psychiatrists
who are treating emotional disorders
by manipulating the chemistries
that are the source nuclei
for which are in the reticular
activating system so
on the basis of
all of that, I argued remember
that affect
is the foundational form of consciousness
and it's intrinsically conscious.
I said that feelings
we don't tend
not only on semantic grounds,
I'm saying that feeling is the basic form
of consciousness.
The reason I'm saying
that is because the basic consciousness
generating tissues of the brain,
the reticular activating system,
which is prerequisite for the activation
of consciousness in cortex,
that this, that these structures
generate feeling,
that feeling therefore is prerequisite
it is foundational
for all forms of consciousness
are then made.
This is a sort of a sidebar.
The reason I went into this third
point
is that namely that the claim that effect
is not synonymous
with into receptive inference.
In other words, that it's not just
an intrinsic to form of perception
as opposed to
the extra receptive forms which have been
the major focus of consciousness
studies over the last few decades
and vision being the main focus.
I'm saying that effect is not.
And why I say this is because
this is increasingly being argued.
In fact,
it was argued by Bud Craig himself.
That effect is just into receptive
perception.
Is the perception
of the state of the own body
is the equivalent of the perception
of the outside world.
In the more typical form
or extra set, the form of perception
that's been equated with consciousness.
I made the point that there's
that there's good reason
to believe that effect isn't just a sixth
modality of perception.
And the evidence that I presented for
that was of various kinds for example,
that there are ethics
which are clearly not receptive.
For example,
getting a fright with being startled
or feeling pain when, when, when,
when you put this stuff into your finger.
These are all extra receptive forms
of stimulation,
and yet they arouse affective responses.
So an affect
clearly is not uniquely inter receptive.
And then I also made the point
that there are many inter
receptive perceptual states
which are not affective.
You can feel your tummy grumbling
or you can feel your heart beating
or you can feel your
your lungs expanding.
And these are not
intrinsically affective phenomena.
So the intercept of perception can happen
without affect
an affect can happen
without into receptive perception.
And so I was trying to draw a line
under the idea
that effect
is just another modality of perception.
I think that by detaching effect
from perception casts
some new light on the hard problem.
And so that's where I went next.
And I reminded you
that David Chalmers,
who coined the hard problem
said that when we look at
functions, perceptual functions
like vision,
which was, as I said, the model example
derived from the
or grounded upon the assumption
that consciousness
is a cortical phenomenon
and cortical vision became the model
example of consciousness.
This was following Crick's
initiative in the mid 1990s.
Crick's idea
was that if we can, if we can identify
the neural correlate of consciousness
in the case of cortical vision,
then we can generalize from that, that
by, by, by discerning the mechanism
whereby a visual information processing
gets turned into conscious vision
in the cortex.
By isolating that mechanism
we will be able to understand
the nature and function of consciousness.
And Chalmers said that that's not true.
If you, if you isolate, identify
the mechanism of visual information
processing like this map.
Yeah, it does.
It doesn't tell you anything about why
there's something it is like you see,
and he he used the
well known knowledge argument
to Frank Jackson,
the story about about Mary,
the visual neuroscientist
who knows everything about all of this.
And I slightly simplified the story
by saying,
well, let's
let's imagine that Mary is blind,
even though she knows everything
about the functions of cortical vision.
She knows everything about the mechanism
whereby visual information
is processed in the cortex
because she's blind, she knows nothing
about what it is like to see.
And if she were to be gifted
suddenly with a normal sight,
then she would learn something
completely new about vision.
She would learn what it is like to see
red and blue what blueness and redness,
et cetera, are like,
none of which is accounted for
by this information
processing flow diagram
and none of what she knew
about the functional mechanisms
of cortical vision
that would have prepared too
for what it is like to see.
In other words, there's other there's
there's something some something else
about visual information processing
other than the sort
of things that mechanistic
functionalist
dissections like this provide us with.
It doesn't that this
this mechanistic account doesn't predict
what that there should be
anything that it is like to see.
And this is the grounds upon
which people like Chalmers say
that a mechanistic and account
of the functional mechanism
of act,
cognitive and perceptual processes.
It doesn't tell us anything about why
there is something
that is like to do
to perform these processes.
And this is the essence
of the hard problem.
I said that I thought that this might be
because they were looking
in the wrong place, that visual
perception and, and,
and all forms of cortical perception
and indeed not only perception
but learning and cognition
more generally
that this can readily go on unconsciously
that these
are not
intrinsically conscious processes,
that it is perfectly possible
to see and to recognize faces
and to read with comprehension
and even to discriminate colors.
These are all uniquely cortical processes
and they can all go on
in the dark, as it were.
In other words,
you do not have to be conscious
of what you're perceiving
in order to perceive it.
And so this this costs
all the different light on Thomas's point
that all of this information
processing can go on in the dark.
So, you know, consciousness
this isn't accounted for
by our normal functionalist
and mechanistic, mechanistic
way of doing cognitive neuroscience.
So I was saying, well, that's
because they're looking at functions
like perception and functions
like learning, which which are not
these are not intrinsically
conscious processes.
And I drew your attention to
this other statement of Thomas's
from his famous paper
in which he says, In summary,
there is no cognitive function
such that we can say in advance
that the explanation of the function
will automatically explain experience.
And my point was, well, that's
because they're talking
about cognitive functions.
I could Chalmers make the same statement
if we were talking about
affective functions, I'm saying, no,
he could not.
I'm saying that we can say in advance
that explanation
of the function of feeling
will automatically explain experience,
because the function of feeling
is to feel it's intrinsically conscious
is this is this function
unlike vision and perception
in general and cognition
as a whole,
none of that is intrinsically conscious,
but feeling affective feeling
is intrinsically conscious.
You could not understand
the mechanism of affective feeling.
It didn't account for why
it feels like something
because that's
the whole point of feeling.
So this question of Chalmers is why
is the performance of these functions
accompanied by experience?
Why doesn't all this information
processing go on in the dark
free of any inner feel?
I'm saying that that question
is perfectly reasonable.
When asked of these cognitive functions
which are not intrinsically conscious,
that kind of information
processing can go on in the dark
free of any in the field.
But that is not true
of feeling, of affective feeling.
And so
my claim, and
this is where we got to last time,
this is now I'm now starting
with a new arguments about my claim,
is that if we can identify
the functional mechanism
of affect of affective feeling,
then we will be able to explain
why this sort of information
processing doesn't go on in the dark
so I hope that that's clear.
That's kind of like my main point.
My main point is we've been,
we've been looking in the wrong place
and we've been looking to cortical vision
and cortical perceptual
and cognitive processes in general.
And in order to isolate
the neural correlates of consciousness
and traumas, has said, well,
it doesn't work.
You can isolate the mechanism
whereby this sort of in these sorts
of information processing goes on
and it doesn't tell you anything about
why this is something
it is like to see, et cetera.
And so my argument is, yes,
that's true of those processes,
but it's not true of effort effect that
remember what
I've said to you in my summary, not today
that this is the most concentrated
consciousness generating tissue,
that there is the reticular
activating system and Perry Aqueduct
Gray is where the lights are switched on
and that the you need you can
switch those lights off
with as small a lesion
as two cubic millimeters in extent
so this is the place where we should
obviously have been looking
in the first place.
And in order to understand the
to identify the neural current
into consciousness
and to enter
and to understand its mechanism.
And and much more important than that
is the fact that
the kind of consciousness it generates
in that namely feeling is
it is it is an intrinsically conscious
mechanism.
That feeling
and it wouldn't exist if it wasn't felt.
And so unlike vision and
and learning and cognition in general,
which does not does not have to be felt,
that affect does have to be felt.
That's the whole point of effect.
So I'm saying that if we could understand
the mechanism of affect,
in other words, the mechanism
whereby feeling comes about,
then we might make some progress
with this hard problem of consciousness.
So remember,
that's how far we got last time.
And now I go on to an
I'm not going to slow down a little bit
because I'm now getting to argue,
try to
identify what
the functional mechanism of affect is.
But I thought perhaps before I do that,
I should pause for a moment in case there
any questions
arising from my summary of my argument
so far
it's good to carry on.
Thank you, Mark.
OK, thanks.
So might you see
I'm saying
effort is an extended form of homeostasis
and by the way, this is not my argument.
This is an argument
that was first to my knowledge,
first introduced by Ansip in the 1990s,
subsequently
popularized
by Antonio Damasio
so I'm just summarizing
my version of what is in fact now
a good at 25 year old argument
what I mean is Stacey's is
probably the most basic
biological mechanism.
It could be said that homeostasis is what
enables living
organisms to resist the second law
of thermodynamics.
In other words, it is what enables them
to be living organisms
and they don't just dissipate
they remain in an organized form
and the basis of this is homeostasis
and that rather than just explore
all possible states
we living, things have to remain
within highly specific states.
And these are called the
the settling point
or the set point,
the viable ranges of the organism.
And this applies across
multiple different parameters
let me use the example of cool body
temperature.
For those of us
who think in degrees Celsius,
we have to remain between 36 and a half
and 37 and a half degrees Celsius.
That's where we need to be.
If we, if we deviate too far
from that very narrow range
then we are at risk of dying.
And that
doesn't apply only to temperature,
it applies to water,
to oxygen to salt,
to sugar, to blood pressure,
to all sorts of things about our,
our bodies.
There have to remain
within very narrow ranges
that are viable with the preservation
of out of our living state.
If we move outside of those ranges
in other words,
if we explore all possible states,
then we die.
So we have to work
against that dissipate.
If a trend, as I said,
that is this entropic trend.
We have to resist entropy and and
and remain within our viable states
and very narrow specific ranges
of of viability across these multiple
dimensions of our physiology.
And this is why I say
that homeostasis is what keeps us alive.
Now, a deviation from that
settling point
then becomes a demand for work.
The organism has to do something
to return itself.
To its viable bounds.
And that's the basic mechanism
of homeostasis.
That's
how all of those autonomic functions
I was talking about earlier
like core body
temperature and blood gas balance
and so on, that's how they work.
If you're moving outside of your range,
you have to do something
to retain yourself into the range.
That is what homeostasis is.
It's the it's the mechanism
that returns us back to our viable range.
Now, what I'm saying is that affect
is an extended form of homeostasis.
And how it extends homeostasis
is that when we move out
of our viable range, we feel it.
We feel an unpleasant quality.
That means
I am moving out of my viable range.
And by contrast, if you're moving back
towards your viable range,
you have pleasurable feeling.
And this seems to be the basic function
of ethics that enables the organism
to know how it's doing in terms
of its organism.
OK, viability.
So the organism feels
when it's moving outside of its viable
range
as unpleasant, which means this is bad
and it feels moving back
towards its viable range, back towards
its ideal settling point as pleasure,
which means this is good,
this predicts my survival, this predicts
my demise.
So feelings are rooted in a value system.
In other words, that there is
something good and there's something bad.
And what is good is to survive
and as it happens to reproduce
and what is bad is to not do so.
This is, of course the basic value system
that underwrites all of life.
This is the value system
that underwrites natural selection.
So the
feelings are rooted in that value system.
And what they do
is they enable the organism subjectively
the organism itself to know
whether it's
moving out of its viable bounds.
In other words, whether it's doing
something bad within that value system.
Or something good
within that value system.
That's what feelings do they enable
the organism
to know how they are doing
within that value system.
Now, why?
Why does this get added to homeostasis?
Because not all homeostasis is felt
that most homeostasis
is entirely autonomic.
And I was mentioning earlier
blood pressure, for example,
when you move out of your variable
range your heart rate changes
and your that
the your blood vessels dilate
in order to
return, you
to your viable blood pressure.
And you don't need to know.
In fact,
you do not know anything about it.
And in fact, it's clinically notorious
how blood pressure regulation works
because you can be way out of your viable
bounds and know nothing about it.
And I'm just using blood
pressure is an example of that.
Then there are many,
many many ways in which your autonomic
nervous system
maintains you within your viable bounds
without you doing anything about it.
So why do we need to feel it?
Well, there
what feeling adds up
is when you are in a situation
of uncertainty and a situation
where you do not have a readily
a pre prepared reflex
which returns you
to your viable bounds so
you don't need to feel how you're doing
if you don't have to make any choices,
if you have automatic predictions
which return you by reflex,
like in the case of blood pressure
regulation that to your viable bounds,
then you you the sentient being
have no part to play in the process.
What, what,
where feeling comes into its own
is where the organism finds itself
in a state of uncertainty
for example in a novel situation
for which it's it's innate
pre wired as it were reflexes
have no have no preparedness
and you find yourself
in a state of surprise
and now what you're going to do and the
if there's no reflexive
solution available,
then a feeling enables
the organism to make choices.
The choices
have to be rooted in a value system.
There has to be a good choice
and a bad choice.
Otherwise it's random.
So whether you're doing the right thing
or the wrong thing is
is announced to you by how it feels
so this enables voluntary action.
I really must emphasize
that this enables you to choose.
It enables you to decide for yourself
what to do.
Things are getting worse.
So I'm going to change my mind.
Things are getting better.
I will stick with this policy.
This is working so these are not
these are not hardwired.
These are not innate predictions.
These are choices
made on the fly by the organism.
Here and now.
And they enable the organism
to survive in states of uncertainty.
In other words,
in unpredicted situations,
in other words, in novel situations
and God knows they are many of those in
life. So
just to put flesh to those
bones,
let me give you an illustrative example
and it's normally respiratory
control is autonomic risk.
You don't need to make any decisions
about breathing
it just happens automatically.
So you automatically remain
within your viable bounds
in terms of the ratio of oxygen
to carbon dioxide.
But that's only when the normal
autonomic reflexes
manage the situation
because you are in predictable
circumstances.
Now, imagine that you are in a carbon
dockside filled room.
Now suddenly you move out of your viable
bronze
bounds and breathing
normally normal reflexive regulation
of the of of your respiratory system
doesn't work
because ordinary breathing in this
in this carbon
dioxide filled room
is going to rapidly lead to your demise.
So now you've got to do something.
You've got to get you've got to
you've never been in a burning
building before,
let alone this particular one.
So you have no you have no reflex
or instinct,
no innate prediction as to what to do.
So you feel your
way through the situation.
And please note at this point,
at the point when you find yourself
in this unexpected situation,
this is where this is where your need
for oxygen becomes conscious.
So this is a very important point.
And otherwise autonomic function
now becomes a conscious function
and you feel what we call
air hunger or suffocation along
and you now you move
about in this building deciding
which way to go.
Remember, you have no
you know, prior knowledge of what to do
and it's only on the basis
of how it feels.
So if, for example, you go upstairs
and the oxygen supply diminishes
and you feel worse, air hunger,
if you go downstairs and there, there's
a greater provision of oxygen,
then you feel better.
You feel relief
from the suffocation along.
And so the feelings tell you whether
what you're doing is working or not.
And so your choices are based on feeling.
And so you are able to feel your way
through this problem.
And survive.
This is not a small advantage.
The ability to survive in unpredicted
environments
is an enormous adaptive advantage.
And so that, we believe, is
what the function of feeling is.
That's why in this narrow example, why
respiratory control suddenly becomes
conscious that that that it
dramatically intrudes on consciousness.
Suddenly your need for oxygen.
And the purpose of this is to enable you
to calibrate your choices
to to
to to change your mind about your policy,
your current policy on the basis
of whether it's working or not,
which is, which is exactly what
feeling announces for you.
In the absence of feeling
you would behave randomly and
one in a million will do the right thing,
and that one will survive and reproduce,
and the rest of you have had it.
So this enables us to make choices
within our own lifetime.
But we don't have to let natural
selection do it within our own lifetimes.
We can adapt to unpredicted situations.
And of course, once you've done that, you
then also can learn from the experience
within your own lifetime.
And so the next time you find yourself
in a burning building,
you might on the basis of,
of, of learning from experience,
you might have somewhat less uncertainty
about what to do
so again, let me just make sure
that I'm getting across my main point,
because this is the mechanism of feeling.
This is the function of feeling.
This is what feeling does.
This is why the organism must feel it.
Now, remember what Chalmers had said
that, you know,
why doesn't all this information
processing go on in the dark and so on?
And that was built upon
an earlier argument by Tom Nagle,
who said an organism
as conscious mental states
if and only if there is something
that it's like to be that organism,
something it's like for the organism.
Then he went on to say, if we acknowledge
that a physical theory of mind
must account for the subjective
character of experience,
we must admit that no presently available
conception gives us a clue
about how this could be done.
So this is what I'm trying to do
in this talk.
I'm trying to give us a clue
about how this could be done
as this is enables
way of formulating a hard problem.
Why and how is this something
it's like to be an organism,
something it's like for the organism?
My point is that that question
only makes sense in relation to things
like visual information processing,
which it does not have to be something
it is like to to see
that does not have to be something.
It is like to discriminate
read from move.
You can do that unconsciously.
The cortex can do that.
Automatically.
That kind of information
processing can go on in the dark.
But would you would
would Thomas even have asked?
I mean, Nagle
even have asked this question
if we were talking about feeling,
I've just explained to you
what the function of feeling is,
and it makes it kind of absurd to ask why
and how is this something?
It is like to be an organism, something
it's like for the organism.
I hope that you can see what I mean, why
and how there is something
it is like to be an organism,
something it is like for the organism
has everything to do with feeling.
It feeling is, is what it is
like to be an organism,
how you're doing as an organism.
How much longer are you going
to remain in existence as an organism?
That's what feeling is like.
And, and this is why and how it exists.
So if we can get to what
the physical mechanism going back to what
to what to what Nagle was saying here
and he said,
if we acknowledge
that the physical theory of mind
must account for this
something that is likeness
then he's saying, we have to admit that
we currently have no clue
that I'm saying it's because
we've been looking in the wrong place.
I think if we look to feeling
and we seek a physical theory of feeling,
this will account for the subjective
character of experience
and we will make some progress.
This will provide us some clue
about how we might
go about solving this hard problem
so my next
point so let me pause at that point.
Having said that effect
is an extended form of a disease.
That's my next claim.
Let's see if anybody wants to argue the
toss or make a comment or ask a question.
Yeah.
So, Stephen, there's
no need to raise a hand after each point.
We'll take any questions.
So go for it, Stephen and then Dave,
if you have anything.
Thank you.
Yes, thank you.
Really, really enjoying this.
I'm interested in this awareness
that leads to the homeostatic
sort of correction.
And if it's where the awareness is with
the actual cells or organs
struggling in some way to act or enact
upon the surprise
or to be that in the environment
that they're encountering
at different scales.
So this this issue of actually action
or inaction
and when that action and inaction
can functionally
correlate up the nested hierarchies,
then it's those actions
or the inability
to act in the way that cells would like.
That then is becoming the signal
of what or where action is failing
rather than necessarily a signal of
that actually contains information
inherently in it.
I wonder what your thoughts
would be on that.
Yes, I agree.
If I'm understanding you correctly,
I agree with the emphasis on action.
So I'll I'll slightly run
ahead of myself if I say this.
Obviously, a homeostatic deviation
can also be construed
as a prediction error.
In other words, what you would
what you're doing has not led
to the outcome that was expected.
And the two ways
of correcting prediction errors.
And you can either you can either
change your prediction
or you can change what you're doing
in order to bring about the prediction
that you had originally.
In other words, and when it comes to
when it comes to prediction error,
you can either update the prior
and have a posterior prediction
or you got to do something differently
in order to confirm the prior prediction.
So that's where the emphasis is on
action.
Now, why this is so important
in relation to homeostasis
is that you can't change your prediction
about what your viable bones are.
You know, if you expect to be between 56
and a half and 37 and a half degrees
Celsius on the basis of acting
in a certain way, in other words,
a firing and autonomic reflex
and you then find yourself to be at 39
degrees Celsius.
You can't say, OK,
my posterior prediction is that by doing
this I'll be 59 degrees Celsius
because if you do that, you're on that,
you're rapidly on the road to death.
So, so the emphasis, so
the prediction error has to be corrected
on the basis
of changing your action policy,
doing something different in order
to confirm your prior prediction.
So, so the emphasis is
very much on action when it comes
to these organism
predictions, these, these phenotypic
the the
viable states for your phenotype
can't be changed.
So you can't just up
you can't just change your mind
about what you expect
will flow from your actions.
You have to change your actions
in order to bring about the expected
or preferred state of your phenotype.
Thanks.
And I'll just add one piece to that.
I think that's really helpful.
And also in terms of like multiple scales
going down to smaller scales.
So for instance,
if I actually feel heat in my body
and my body might be
my cells are trying to act
to find a better state that can be seen
as oppressive and claustrophobic.
If I then read that as being me
getting into an uncomfortable state,
it could also be me
basking in the sun on a beach,
you know, in the same way that if I taste
something that's very sour, there's
some sort of action at the cell or the
or the organ level
reacting to that sound.
So that sweetness, which could be like
a nice confectionery, sweet for a child,
you know, like one of these gob stoppers
or it could be quite a
problem.
So I think
I like what you're saying with action.
I was wondering whether that that action
piece is
the inaction is the prediction error
in terms of how it can go up in terms
of these these nested hierarchies
of of physical scale.
Yes. So again, I must be careful
not to run ahead of myself too much.
I mean, inevitably, you know,
you must ask whatever question comes
into your mind at any point,
but I am aware that as I go
down this list of of of arguments,
I'm going to be addressing those points.
So I don't want to make
all of those arguments in one go.
So I will just say that for now
that that what you've just asked has,
first of all, a lot to do with the fact
that we have multiple needs
that there's not only one needs,
that they have to be balanced in relation
to each other.
And also very importantly, that we're
talking about a predictive hierarchy
that this is
what you're speaking about with reference
to scale, that what applies
at the sensory periphery and what applies
at the core of the predictive hierarchy
have different implications
for the way that that affect works.
So I'm just saying those
very kind of vague and abstract things
for now, and I hope that the picture
will become clearer as I proceed.
Thank you, Mark.
Yes, Dave, go for it.
Yeah.
I don't know how to state this clearly.
This is some thinking that I got into
from listening
to a very recent interview you did with
young man in another part of Capetown,
talking about perception
and I think for
and maybe this has already been done.
I just haven't run across the research
that there's a larger framework in which
these notions of what can be perceived,
what can be perceived consciously,
what is a sensory
modality, what we don't call a sense.
It seems that there are on the one hand,
conditions we've been calling
those homeostatic conditions
that you can't do anything about
your body either
adjusts the blood pressure
internally or it goes haywire,
which you can't be aware of it.
So we don't think about this as something
that we can consciously perceive
and we don't call the mechanisms
that are sensitive
to blood pressure and
core temperature
and other things as matters
of sensation, not as of perception,
matters of consciousness.
On the other
side.
The other side of the map.
And there are single objects
influences
a mechanism that is sensitive
only to blood pressure
presents
another reason, not to call this a sense.
An eye spot just tells us certain
kinds of ones there's light around here
or there isn't light around here.
No directionality, just it's daytime
or it is I'm under the mud or
I'm not under the mud.
Where as even
a little more information,
more kinds of information qualify
this more as a sensory modality
and in
things like hearing and vision
and smell, we have this very rich need.
And there's many things you can do
about that, many things
you can do about a burning smell.
And there are many kinds of odors
out there.
So this tie,
the thing you're thinking about. Yes.
So the first thing
that you're touching on
there is the fact that homeostasis
is only part of the story.
In fact, the the example
I gave earlier of the of the person
who finds themselves in a carbon dioxide
filled room in a burning building,
they need to maintain
their homeostatic blood gas balance.
But there's nothing that the autonomic
nervous system can do about that.
They therefore need to turn
to the to action in the outside world.
So when I said that the person starts
moving about upstairs and down
and then feels,
is this working or is this not,
is this good
or is this bad that we call Alastair
this?
It's acting in the outside world
in order to return myself
to Mommy Esthetic Arms.
So that's the first thing
I just wanted to make clear.
I know it's implicit
and I know I'm telling you something
that you very, very well,
but I just want to make that explicit
for, for, for our participle it's
that what the importance
of the outside world
for these internal bodily states
the bridge from homeostasis
to other states,
this is how we conceptualize that.
So then it moves to the next point
which is that
think about those kids that I showed you
earlier who have no cortex
and all they're capable of feeling
is their affect and they don't they can't
they can't consciously
think I feel like this about that.
In other words,
they don't know what the about that is.
They just feel things
and they can't include
within their consciousness of the feeling
and what the thing in the outside world
is that contextualizes that feeling,
the context doesn't become conscious,
only the feeling itself to be able
to extend the feeling onto the context,
to be able to say, in effect,
I feel like this about that incorporates
the context within that
that terrain of uncertainty where one's
navigating the one's palpating
the uncertainty in order to make choices
not only on the basis of blind feeling,
but also on the basis
of what kind of object
brings about this change in my feeling
and what kind of object brings
about that.
For all of that to be incorporated
within the realm of consciousness,
I think is a further leap and clearly
another enormous adaptive advantage.
So the first leap is just to be able
to feel the consequences of your actions.
The second leap is to be able to picture,
as it were,
your those actions
within the sphere of consciousness and,
and in this way
to bring the context into consciousness
and extend the
realm of choices enormously.
Thank you, Mark.
And I'll
just chime in with a third question.
So you mentioned
homeostasis is only part of the story.
And in the chat broadcast
what part of the story is for me since
I didn't know that word?
So a small stress inducing
like some kind of benefit
over the integrated time horizon,
like in exercise stress
that leads to improved strength.
You mentioned Aloe Stacy's
kind of an anticipatory movement towards
a set point, but where does, for example,
induced stress, mild stress and recovery
play into this extended homeostatic
or generalized homeostatic framework?
So sorry,
I didn't understand what you meant.
So, you know,
I think again, when one gives
an overview of a
of a of an argument like this one
always oversimplifies
why one sort of has to simplify.
You know, when I say that homeostasis
that, you know, you always have
to confirm your prior prediction
that that's not entirely true.
There are also ways in which
the homeostatic range can be extended.
The homeostatic ranges,
I mean like for example,
you know what I was saying about oxygen?
You can, you can if you're a diver,
you know, you can learn
how to how to hold your breath
and how to manage the stress
of being out of your viable blood
gas range
in a way that's naive
a person like, like, like I cannot.
So they are, they are mechanisms
whereby these, these things can in very,
very narrow limits.
These things can be changed.
But I think the emphasis
there has to fall on the narrow limits.
Ultimately, there is there is an outer
limit to you, a viable range.
And this is the driving mechanism
of the story that I'm talking about. You
thank you.
Of course.
So much more to say
and learn and add, but please carry on.
Thank you.
Well, you can see highlighted
on the screen now my next point
and it might seem like a small point,
it might seem like an obvious point
that complex organisms
require multiple obvious debts.
And in fact, I've more or less said
this already, but I want to make explicit
and here is the same slide
that you saw a moment ago
where I've just added the point
that I have now that I'm now making up
the importance of this point is that
we have multiple needs
which must be categorically distinguished
from one another.
In other words, we can't have
a continuous variable called need
that that variable has to be fact
arised
across a number of different categories.
So let me be clear
what I'm talking about.
Imagine you have if we quantify
on a continuous and a scale
how much deviation there is from where
you need to be, let's say, OK, I've got
I've got six out of ten
of first and I've got four out of ten
of sleepiness.
Then all that means I've got
ten out of 20 of total need.
And so all I need to do is sleep.
I don't need to drink
and if I, if I can generalize
from that little example there,
the point that I'm trying to make
is that, no, that's not true.
You have to sleep and you have to drink
and you have to eat
and you have to defecate
and you have to breathe.
You can't just submit to all of these
and, and bring down the total number.
If you did that, you would die.
So we have to recognize that
each one of these needs
has to be met in their own right.
And that means we need to know
we can't just have a total
variable called need.
We need to know which need
or we're talking about and this is why.
And they have to be treated
as categorical variables.
In other words,
this here we're talking about how much
how much water I'm lacking.
Yeah, we're talking about how much oxygen
I'm lacking.
Yeah, we're talking about how much sleep
I'm lacking, et cetera.
So that they can be
so that the category of need
that the organism finds itself in
can be addressed
appropriately.
The appropriate category
needs to be addressed.
And I know what I'm saying
sounds absolutely obvious,
but why it's important is that it's
because of this, because of the points
I've just been making.
And that hunger feels different
from thirst,
and thirst feels different
from suffocation alone.
And suffocation alone feels different
from sleepiness and sleepiness
feels different from pain and so on,
because each one of these feelings
and the quality of the feeling tells
us which need is is at issue
and categorical variables
are distinguished qualitatively.
So we are not only talking about
valence goodness or badness and arousal,
how much or how little are talking
also about qualitative categories.
And I think that's important.
When we come back to the
whole point of what
I'm talking about, namely qualia,
you know, namely
the qualitative stuff of
of of what it is like to do anything,
be anything.
Those those qualitative distinctions.
It's of the essence of consciousness
that that is qualitative.
It has qualitative differentiations.
It's not just some total quantitative,
some total, a continuous matter of need.
It's a matter of different
categories of need,
which therefore are different
qualities of need.
And I think that's important in terms
of understanding what an affect is.
And that fact is a state of the organism
registered by the organism.
In other words,
it is intrinsically subjective.
It has intrinsic value, valence,
goodness and badness,
which has existential consequences
for the organism.
And in addition to that, it has quality.
It is inherent in the nature of ethics
that they are qualitatively distinct
from each other.
And I hope
and I hope that this very simple,
functional, mechanistic
reasoning that I've given you
as to why that needs to be the case,
why that must be the case,
helps to
to make clear why ethics
take the form that they do it.
Remember, what we are doing here
is addressing and enables question about,
you know, why is this something
it is like to be an organism
and how does it come about that
there is something
it is like to be an organism
for an organism.
That's something it is like this is not
just a valence goodness and badness,
but also a qualitatively
differentiated state,
subjective state of the organism.
So I think that by by reducing
the mechanism of ethics
to these essential features,
we begin to see why
it takes the form that it does, why it is
and necessarily conscious something
in the sense that the rudimentary sense
that I'm defining consciousness.
So that's why this point is important
and that's why I wanted to make the point
clearly that complex organisms
require multiple categorical homeostatic.
They need to be treated
as categorical variables.
They need therefore to be
that they need to be qualified.
Each of these different factors of need,
each of these different
categories of need
have to be qualitatively differentiated
from each other.
And this is, I think, the ground zero
of where qualia come from.
Now, I'll go on to my next point,
which is that these different categories
of need must be prioritized and again,
I think this is
this is in a way an obvious point,
but it's but I want to just dwell on it
for a moment
and to, to, to to
draw out some of the
some of the implications of this.
I said earlier that our autonomic
hobbyist stats run
well autonomously most of the time.
In other words, there are automatic
automated predictions,
which we call reflexes,
that are when the organism moves
out of its viable bounds,
then it fires these reflexes which
bring it back into its viable bounds.
And then I told you that not all of our
needs can be dealt with that way.
Some of them, as we move outside
of the range of what the
autonomic reflex can
achieve, like, for example,
when it comes to thermoregulation,
you start to perspire
if you get too hot, this is a reflex.
You start to breathe more shallowly
and rapidly panting.
In other words, that's a reflex these are
autonomic responses to overheating.
Then they reach a certain limit,
you know,
that they they
haven't cooled you down adequately.
So then you've got to do something.
You're going to do something
like leave the kitchen.
And that is that is that is
what I've just said applies
to one of your multiple obvious debts.
In other words, one of them now requires
allostatic action.
And you now need to do something
in the outside world.
And clearly you can't do something
in the outside world
in relation
to all your needs simultaneously.
So all the time you're sliding,
you know, you're,
you're, you're your hydration,
your water in relation to salt
content of your body
sliding all the time.
It doesn't mean that you're thirsty
all the time.
You're you're burning up the,
the sugars in your adipose tissues
all the time.
It doesn't mean
you're hungry all the time.
So the question
is you know, what gets prioritized
and and there must be some prioritization
because you can't do everything at once
when it comes to voluntary activity
in the outside world,
you have to prioritize.
There's an action bottleneck.
And the point I'm making here is first
of all, just simply that
that you do have to prioritize.
And secondly, that what is prioritized
is what becomes conscious.
In other words,
as I gave in the example of suffocation,
the law, that that business carries
on unconsciously until it becomes
prioritized at that point, it
forcibly intrudes on consciousness.
And my priority now is I need oxygen.
And that's what you feel the other needs
this is the other point I'm making.
The other needs don't disappear
at that point.
They continue to be regulated,
but they are regulated automatically.
So the prioritization of a need brings
that need into the realm
of palpating uncertainty.
In other words, into the realm of feeling
your way through the problem. And
this, I think, is an important mechan
an important part of
how of how feeling works.
So let me
remember I said I was going to talk
about the Perry Aqueduct.
Great.
So and I was going to tell you
how this plays in
as important, if not more important role
in the basic machinery
of consciousness of the upper brainstem,
then the reticular activating system
and the Perry Aqueduct, or Gray,
which is just a 14 millimeter
long structure column, the structure
around the central canal of the midbrain
and all of our homeostatic
mechanisms in other words,
all of the multiple Humvee assets.
And we have many, all of the multiple
omnibus debts, all of them
send their residual errors, signal
to the Perry Aqueduct, operate
the Perry Aqueduct will graze
like a final common pathway
of all of these
homeostatic errors signals.
And it seems that this is where the
prioritization must be must be going on.
The the the
the the the the the determining
which of the current error
signals is the most salient
then gives rise to.
And this is an argument I must again
make clear this is not an argument of
this is not my own novel insight.
This was a beautifully argued on
comparative anatomical grounds
by beyond Mecca
in his in his in a brilliant paper
in behavioral and brain sciences
so he he recognized that
the Perry aqueduct
gray together with the superior calculi
that I showed you earlier
and the midbrain locomotor region,
they form what
he called a midbrain selection triangle.
In other words,
this is where the ethic, the need
that is to be prioritized is selected.
And this gives rise to a feeling,
the feeling being as in the example
that I gave with suffocation, alarm,
the need that is prioritized, the need
that is currently most salient,
the need that is going to now
color your consciousness,
qualify your consciousness, in terms
of its most rudimentary property.
In other words, the feeling, the affect,
what state,
what organism, state am I in?
I'm in a state of respiratory distress.
I'm in a state of suffocation a lot.
That's what I feel.
Why? It's because that
this is where choices need to be made.
This is where the creature needs to feel.
The person in that example needs
to feel their way through the problem.
The other needs remain
at the other needs.
The non prioritized needs are not raised
to the level of feeling
and and I hope it's there. Why?
And we need to understand mechanistically
how does all of this work?
And that leads to my next point.
So before I go to that next point,
let me just pause again in case there
any comments or questions
about this prioritization function
performed by the Perry Aqueduct or Gray,
which is what determines
what affective state you are going to be
in from one moment to the next.
In other words,
which need is which need is going to
is going to qualify
you your affective state
thank you, Mark.
Dave then Stephen.
Yeah.
I just want to throw out there
in Sylvan Thompkins later work
that is after 1970 he came to
elevate reset
to the status of a fundamental emotion
and I think it's very relevant to this
the notion of suddenly shifting
from one conscious emotion
or one conscious activity
or world attitude to another.
I, I I believe York concept drew pretty
heavily on Tompkins and the reason that
he doesn't hate him in a lot of detail
is that he accepted so much of kind of
like what you said about
I agree almost totally with
over the,
the britisher whose father's from India.
I'm sorry, I'm blanking on this.
Then we had a dialog
with in just a few months ago
am I completely
wrong about and are you talking about.
Yes, thank you.
Am I completely wrong?
This just, just did this was time.
Did Tompkins simply grow no.
I agree with that completely.
Tompkins, the reason that thanks
it doesn't cite him
barely ever cites him
usually in in the beginning
of a kind of a general discussion.
You know, just just to say
this is the tradition I belong to
and then and then carries
on building on on his shoulders.
I agree with that very much that that's
thank you, Stephen.
Yeah.
I liked the when you talked
about Palpatine uncertainty
and the silence around that
so that that's a nice term.
And I think that relates to like
what is going on, so to speak.
So what about what's going on?
And then now what happens next?
And I'm wondering though as well
if the
idea of
where which I think is often left out,
there's a lot of categorization
of what things are, but where is it
happening that makes a difference
in terms of how significant
it might be in terms of prioritization
so I was wondering how much
the risk of the awareness
of some sort of disequilibrium happens
could be featured in this.
And maybe that's
where the physical ization
and the specialization
becomes much more significant.
Than when you're just starting
with the brain yes.
So well, all of these
homeostatic mechanisms, of course,
the physiological processes
that they regulate or widely distributed,
but the control centers of these
homeo states
are for the most part
in the brain stem broadly defined
and I say broadly defined
because there are some
that are in the middle
oblongata and pons,
but there's some
that are in the midbrain,
there are some that are Diane symbolic.
And for example, let me just mentioned
the most outstanding example.
The hypothalamus is full of
homeostatic control centers
but know so
so hypothalamus
circum ventricular organs,
the para brachial complex,
the area post-trauma,
the nucleus, solid Taurus,
these are all
homeostatic control centers, but
a fundamental importance
and I think it's not
sufficiently recognized,
although Maca certainly made much of it,
that all of these nuclei
that I have just enumerated,
they in turn project to
the peri aqueduct will grade
the peri aqueduct,
while Gray is in my view a matter home.
Yes matter homeostatic sort of the
the the the
the control center of the control centers
and and that the the essential function
there is a prioritization function watts
and by being able to physically locate
these mechanisms bearing in mind
what where I started I started my answer
to your question by pointing out
that ultimately these ideas that's
regulate physiological processes
which cannot be localized.
They are distributed
processes, politics, excellence.
But the center
the control center can be localized
and those control centers
all they are numerous at once
and they in turn they,
they all send the residual error
signal to peri aqueduct
that that is really important.
Now what that enables us then to do
is to test models like the one that
I'm describing to you, what happens
when one or another of these individual
homeostatic control centers is lengthened
and what happens when the peri aqueduct
for gray as a whole, these lesions
and what happens
I might as well just insert that here
is you get a persistent vegetative state.
In other words, you get that condition
that Magoon and Maruti led us to believe
is is a is a theoretical possibility.
In other words, blank wakefulness.
And remember I said earlier in my summary
of what I said last time I spoke
that the idea that the reticular
activating system
provides merely a quantitative of level
of consciousness
and not any quality or content,
and that that's fictional state
of affairs of blank wakefulness, is
the thing
that the reticular activating system
was supposed to be producing,
which, as I've showed
you, is not the case
because all of those different lines
of evidence that are summarized
show that what the reticular activating
system is producing is anything but
without quality
and without content, that this is in fact
the foundational form of the qualities
and contents
of consciousness,
namely the different effects.
If you lesion the period with the gray,
then you get that fictional state
to that artificial state
of blank wakefulness.
In other words, the these patients
and so they show not unresponsive
wakefulness.
They still have the autonomic sleep
waking cycle.
In other words, they wake up
in the morning and go to sleep at night
like those those hydrogen liquids
that I showed you.
But unlike those kids,
they show no emotional or
no affective, no no response
to their
situation and no intentionality either.
And so, you know, that's
that's what you would expect would occur
if Perry Aqueduct or Gray is where
the ethics are actually being generated,
because remember,
that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying that the prioritization of a
of a homeostatic error
signal is the feeling of that signal.
That is the rendering
conscious of that signal.
And that is what we mean
by feeling something.
It means now, then, now this need is not
just to need, not this need is a drive
now this need is driving
my voluntary behavior.
And that is why it becomes conscious,
because as I said to you earlier,
voluntary behavior can be defined
as the making of choices
as opposed to the executing
of automatons predictions
just to
notes on that when hearing Steven's
questions about spatial localization
and how that can refer to brain
localization as well as like
in the Perry personal space
it made me think about how awareness
a awareness
it could be without awareness.
Awareness could be spatially dislocated
or awareness
might be a highly specialized percept.
And then the other note
that I wanted to make was as a researcher
of distributed physiology,
in the use social insect colony,
this extended homeostatic
perspective leads
to many interesting connections.
When we think about extended
social homeostasis as well, but
just two notes and we can carry on
very good points
so you're saying we can carry on,
meaning I can carry on whichever way
you'd like to.
OK, great.
So I'm not going to move to my to my next
my next claim,
which is,
which is I see we have half an hour left,
so I must I must admit,
it's really quite amazing, you know,
because you are so generous
with giving your speakers 2 hours.
You love us to a false sense of security
and thinking, well, I can just elaborate
as much as I want
to. There's plenty of time.
And now we're
down to our last half hour
and I've still got three points to go.
So it's like no one goes there anymore.
It's too busy.
Yeah.
Well, again, grateful
for the time that you're giving me.
So let me move to this point
and this has everything to do
with the relationship
between affective consciousness
and cognitive consciousness.
I spoke earlier about
I feel like this about that.
In other words, the incorporating
of the of the cognitive domain
within the sphere of feeling
and so this is the point
that I'm making now.
This is a drawing that a diagram
that comes from a paper
that I wrote with Karl Feresten
and and here
the important equation is the third one.
And here this diagram
basically is just trying to spell out
in a visual form
what the what these equations are saying.
So when I said earlier that
we have two ways of
reducing prediction error
when to win a prior
prediction does not lead
to the sensory state that's expected,
then we can either change our perception.
In other words,
we can change the prediction
or we can change our action.
We can do something differently in order
to bring about the prior prediction.
So that's what these two equations
describe,
that we have a generative model
which generates predictions
as to what sensory state
will flow from our actions.
And so here so here
there's an action in the external world
which is predicted
to bring about a certain sensory state.
And to the extent that it does
not bring about that sensory state,
in other words, the difference
here is the prediction error.
And of course the prediction error is
then used to update the generative model
in order to give rise
to better predictions,
in order to better maintain
your expected sensory states.
I need to emphasize here,
because this was not the case
in the early days
of the predictive processing paradigm,
that that colorist and his colleagues
unleashed upon the world.
Sensory states do not necessarily mean
extra set of sensory states.
And so in the examples that I have been
giving in this talk so far
that this would be the equivalent of,
for example, cold
body temperature or blood, oxygen level,
et cetera.
These are the the most important
sensory states for the organism.
Or its viable states in terms of its
homeostatic expectations.
So please remember that
when I speak about actions in the world,
the world that we're talking about here
is the can be the visceral body
and it can be the external world that the
the body, the mark of blanket,
it it's the, the, the,
the body is as much external
to the blanket as the external world.
Is external,
the blanket of the nervous system
I think we've got some reverend
somebodys kitchen.
Yeah.
Which you must put, you must,
if you like,
whoever is doing the dishes, they're just
so, so what, what this equation.
Yeah.
Which is,
which is, which is written in words.
Yeah.
The rate of change of precision
which is, which is omega in the equation.
The rate of change of precision over time
depends on how much free energy changes
when you change precision.
This means that precision will look as
if it's trying to minimize free energy.
The rate of this free energy
minimization process is the difference
between the inverse precision
and the sum of squared prediction errors.
So that's this equation here
put into words,
and it's for granting the central role
that precision plays
in minimizing prediction error so
that the
I want to be clear that this is precision
modulation is in physiological terms
the modulation of postsynaptic gain.
So the message passing going on here
between error signals
and prediction signals
is modulated by hosts.
It's the reticular activating
is modulation of that message pulsing.
So it's that increasing or decreasing
of the gain on the error signals,
that's the role of precision modulation,
which is just the same thing as to say
that is the role of the reticular
activating system.
It is modulating the gain in the message,
pulsing it.
You speak physiologically
that you speak computationally.
It is a matter of increasing
or decreasing precision values
attached to the predictions
over the errors.
So this to put it into different words,
if things are turning out as expected,
that's good
if uncertainty prevails, that's bad.
So increasing confidence in a prediction
is good
in other words, increasing
precision in the prediction is good
at increasing confidence in an error
signal is bad.
In other words, the more uncertainty,
the more you become clear that
things are not turning out as expected
to that extent of course, your confidence
in your current policy is reduced.
In other words, the precision
in your current policy is reduced,
and that just is bad.
So the goodness and badness, the pleasure
and and pleasure
function of precision modulation
that I described to you earlier
is it has this enormously important
contribution
to make to the whole of this mechanism
by determining
the influence of the precision
all over the predictive model.
So to the extent
that precision is reduced
in the error signal
and thereby confidence is maintained
in the policy,
to that extent, the error signal will or
will not have influence
over the parameters
and of the of the predictive model.
And so this is trying to illustrate
the crucial role
that ethic plays in
in this whole predictive mechanism.
So this is the
this is, as it were,
the role of the reticular activating
system of the modulation of the message
passing that goes on in the
these are these are, as it were,
and this synaptic transmission mechanisms
and these are postsynaptic
modulatory mechanisms.
And so I'm just wanting to link
these formalisms
to the affect of rule
that the reticular
activating system plays.
So and this
so just to go back to the statement here,
the mechanism of perceptual
and cognitive consciousness
is precision modulation
of allostatic prediction errors.
In other words, it is the
it is the modulation of confidence
in a current policy.
In other words, the,
the perceived consequences of a current.
So, so as you, as the, as the
a particular need is prioritized,
that need is felt.
This generates
a category of predictive policies.
In other words, this is what I will,
which is what I do in this situation.
In this context that I find myself in.
This is what I expect
the consequences will be.
In other words, these are my expected
and there's an expected precision
attaching to the error signals.
Of course,
it's all the other domains of need.
Remember what I was saying earlier here
about the needs must be prioritized.
The other domains
have monotonous precisions.
So the crucial mechanism
in terms of voluntary action
is that to use the phrase
that one of you said you liked
earlier
is the palpating of the uncertainty.
In other words,
the palpating of the precision
and the adjustment of the confidence
in the current perceptual
and cognitive in other words,
the allostatic aspect of, of,
of what I must do about this needs state,
because there's a state of uncertainty
that's being prioritized there.
There's a changing
of one's mind on the fly.
This is what this mechanism
makes possible.
So it is the effects are,
as it were, a drive
for or a demand for predictive work
for mental work.
And this the modulation, the palpating
of the confidence in the policy over
the error signals is the predictive work
so demanded.
So in other words, the work of
of updating one's policy
of changing one's mind
and it is all of it
underwritten by the affective demand.
So the affect of demand
for predictive work
is what gives rise
to the predictive work itself,
which is the palpating of uncertainties
in the current policy
and the sensory states
that it gives rise to.
And so this is changing your mind
in other words,
in other words, voluntary action, in
other words, the capacity for choice. And
this is the crucial role
that precision modulation
plays in that process. So
that's OK.
Good.
So I think let me just pause for a moment
to see if there are any questions
about that, because I want to
illustrate it with a case
which I think is going to pretty much
take us to to to the end of our time.
So before I launch into this last case,
let's see if anybody has any questions
or comments about that mechanism.
I think we'll go to the case then.
There's always so much to unpack with
defining the variables and understanding
what the edges mean and so on.
But I think the case is a good way
to close this.
OK, so this is,
this is a patient of mine.
Mr s and he had a meningioma here
at the base of his frontal lobes.
It was an olfactory sheath meningioma
and it pushed on his optic nerves.
And as a result of that, he
his vision was, was, was impaired.
And and this is how the tumor
came to attention
and it was successfully,
surgically resected
not because of
its location in relation,
in fact, to the optic nerves.
There was some nervousness
on the part of the surgeon to remove it
and its entirety.
And in fact, he felt it was not possible
to remove it in its entirety.
So he left a little nub of the tumor.
And this regrew
and so the the patient again
noticed these visual difficulties
returned to the surgeon
and the operation had to be repeated
because of scar tissue.
The second operation is always trickier
than the first.
And unfortunately, in
the second operation, there was a bleed
and that bleed was into the basal
forebrain nuclei, small bleed.
But the basal forebrain
nuclei are crucial
these are the upper end of the
of the remember I was saying earlier
that these different parts
of the ascending arousal mechanisms
of the of the brain
that they that they are the source nuclei
for these different neural modulators.
And I spoke of dopamine in that
noradrenaline and serotonin earlier.
Well,
these nuclei are the source nuclei
or they are other source nuclei
for acetylcholine too.
But these are very important source
nuclei for receipt al-kurdi.
Now, remember all of these
what I was saying earlier
about these
at these neural modulatory systems
is that they are modulating postsynaptic
gain, which is just the same thing
physiologically.
Is to say computationally.
They're modulating precision.
That's what they do.
They up and down regulate the precision
in the message pulsing.
And this as I said earlier,
it dictates
which which messages are going
to are going to be selected
and which not.
So it's a
it plays a crucially important role.
Does precision modulation in cognition.
And, and I'm not wanting to show you
this relationship, the relationship
between the affective mechanisms
that I'm talking about,
that is the affect of functions
that are performed
at centrally by peri aqueduct or gray.
And then how this gives rise
to the modulation through these
arousal systems of these different
neurotransmitter systems.
And I'm going to show you
how this worked.
In this case, the seats alkaline and
modulates the confidence in error signals
and so let me just quickly tell you
a little bit more about this patient.
He was he was
56 years
old at the time of the second operation.
And as a result of the damage
to the basal forebrain nuclei
from the second operation,
he woke up from the surgery
with a condition
called confabulate to be amnesia.
So although the tumor was resected
successfully, and the visual problem
was, was was corrected,
he now had this devastating new condition
called Confabulate to Remeasure
Confabulate to re amnesia.
The patient is is it's
not only that they are amnesic,
in other words, that they are unable
to remember, particularly recent events.
But there's also quite a long
retrograde extension to
in other words,
there's quite an impairment
of the retrograde memory
to not only do they have this,
but they also are not aware
of their of their memory problems.
And so when they drew up,
when they
attempt to retrieve a memory,
the memory that they retrieve
is not the correct one.
And they don't realize
it's not the correct one.
And so they have what appear to be false
memories.
These are the confabulations.
They frequently are related in in,
in, in some semantic sense
with the target memory,
with the memory that they're looking for,
there's some semantic relationship
between the memory they find and the one
they're looking for,
but they can be grossly mis
misplaced in space and time.
And so these are what we call
confabulations.
And the patient
is not sufficiently critical of these
remembering as a result of the
the damage
to these neural modulatory mechanisms.
So now this patient, Mr.
S, just to give you one example,
I mean, an extreme example,
he a he had his operation
in Johannesburg,
which is in South Africa,
which is where I hail from.
But at that at the time I was living
and working in London.
And so the surgeon who I knew
well sent the patient to see
me to consult me in London
because I
was doing work with this
with this condition, confabulate amnesia.
So the patient arrives
in London on a Friday
and comes to me on the Monday and
and has no idea
that he's in London because of course
he doesn't remember the journey.
He can't remember anything
from one minute to the next.
And so I say something about, well,
you know,
the surgeon whose name was Mr.
Miller, the surgeon referred you to me
because of this memory difficulty
that you're having.
That's why he sent you to London.
And he said, London,
what do you mean, London?
And I said, Yes,
you know, you're in London.
You don't realize it
because you don't remember the journey
you know, that's the whole point.
This is the kind of
problem that you having. And
he denies it.
He says he's not in London now.
So that's the confabulate,
the respect that these patients
in his memory, his in Johannesburg.
And so he believes he is in Johannesburg.
So I point out to him it was winter
and it was it was snowing outside.
I point out to him
the wintry conditions outside.
You never, by the way,
have snow in Johannesburg.
So I say look out the window he looks at
is absolutely shocked,
but then retorts,
no, I know I'm in Johannesburg.
Just because you're eating pizza
doesn't mean you're in Italy.
That's what he says to me.
So in other words, you know,
you don't have to you know,
you mustn't
overrate the evidence of your senses.
And so that's just an extreme
example of what
I mean by how these patients
how how how them
their amnesia it's
not just a lack of memory.
It's also an excess of confidence
in the in the incorrect memories
that they drew up.
So that's that's the background.
And I saw this man.
The whole point of him being referred
to me is because I treat such patients.
And so I then saw him six days a week
at the same time in
my outpatient clinic at the Royal London
Hospital,
same time, same place he came
with his wife to the waiting room.
I would then go and collect him,
take him up to my consulting room,
spend an hour with him,
take him back down to the waiting room,
and then I would talk to his wife because
he was so full of confabulations.
I needed to verify things in order
to get some sense of what was going on.
And there were certain themes
and this is an interesting thing
about these patients,
these confabulate theory patients.
There's certain themes
that returned again and again.
The patient was an electronic engineer,
but but he
in reality,
he was but he thought the reason
he was coming to me frequently,
he thought he was coming to me to, to, to
because I was consulting him
about an electronic problem. And
otherwise.
He thought that the two of us
were electronic engineers together
working on some electronic problem
also, frequently
he thought that he and I were in
in some sporting team together
that we played rugby together all or we
we were in this rowing team together.
Now, his wife told me he had played rugby
at university
a good 30 years or more before
and likewise
he had, he had been a keen rower,
but this too was at university
more than 50 years before.
And so these are again
good examples of confabulations
into the patient, misallocating in space
and time, a memory that, that
he draws up now
and he has too much confidence in
that is to to to readily accepts
the veracity of
of of the products of his own memory such
so that's the that's the background.
Now on this particular day
that I want to give you a little snippet
of a session from he on this day
when I came to the waiting room
he touched the scar on his head,
the craniotomy scar on his head
and he said hi doc to me
said this was progress.
You know, for the first time
he was associating me with medicine
and he was associating me
with the surgical scar on his head.
And so I thought this was great progress.
And so when we got into my consulting
room, I said to him,
you touched your head
when we met in the waiting room.
And he said, I think the problem is
that a cartridge is missing.
We must we just need the specs.
What was it to see? 49.
Should we order it?
So I said to him,
What does this 49 cartridge do?
He says, Memory, it's a memory cartridge.
A memory implant.
Oh, sorry, I should have mentioned this.
His wife told me that he had had dental
implants,
he'd had serious problems with his teeth
and these had been for many years,
but these problems
had finally been successfully treated
by implants.
Teeth implanted into the into the jaws.
So when he said that
that c 49 cartridges a memory cartridge
and that it's a memory implant
it brought that operation
that dental operation to my mind
he said but I never really understood it.
In fact I haven't used it
for a good five or six months
now it seems we don't really need it.
It was all chopped away by a doctor.
What's his name? Doctor Solms, I think.
But it seems I don't really need it.
The implants work fine.
So I said to him,
You're aware that something's
wrong with your memory,
but and he interrupts me and he says,
Yeah, it's not working 100%,
but we don't really need it.
It was just missing a few beats.
The analysis showed
there was some C or SIO nine missing.
Denise brought me here to see a doctor.
What's his name again?
Doctor Solms or something, and he did
one of those heart transplant things.
So this is referring to another operation
that he'd had,
which is clearly
also being referred to here,
which was that
he had the cardiac arrhythmia,
and so he had a pacemaker
fitted, a cardiac pacemaker.
So he said so he did one of those heart
transplant things
and now it's working
fine. Never misses a beat.
So I said to him, which is what
I actually thought.
I said, You're aware that something is
amiss, some memories are missing.
And of course, that's worrying.
You hope I can fix it
just like those other doctors
fixed the problems with your teeth
and your heart, but you wanted so much
that you're having difficulty
accepting that it's not fixed already.
So he goes on and says, Oh, I see.
Yes, it's not working. 100%.
And he touches his head.
He says, I got knocked on the head,
went off the field for a few minutes,
but it's fine.
Now, I suppose I shouldn't go back on,
but you know me, I don't like going down.
So I asked Tim Noakes.
Tim Noakes, by the way, is a sports
physician in South Africa.
Is this so?
I asked him next, because I've got the
insurance, you know, so why not use it?
Why not go to the best?
And he said, fine, play on.
So that's the end of the snippet
that I wanted to show you.
And by the way,
before I show you about that, so
so this is a case in which due to damage
to one of the precision modulating nuclei
or sets of nuclei,
and in this man's case,
the basal forebrain nuclei
due to the damage to the acetylcholine
and modulating mechanisms
that I showed you earlier,
that he has too much confidence
in his predictions
and too little confidence in the
he does not up the game on the areas
in the say looks.
I say to him he's his predictive
model tells him he's in Johannesburg.
I say to him, no, you're in London.
Look out the window.
He looks out the window, he sees snow.
You know, clearly
not something that could possibly
be associated with Johannesburg.
But he sticks with his prediction.
He says, no, I know I'm in Jo'burg
just because you're eating pizza,
that doesn't mean you're in Italy.
And likewise,
in the case of these memory processes
that I showed you in that session,
each time
that he starts to feel
the pleasure of the mounting error
signals,
the mounting, that things are said,
just think about it.
He has he touches his head.
He's on the brink of being aware
that he's he's had a brain operation
that the brain operation
has resulted in loss of memory.
I hope you can
see that to him saying that
he says we just need to order the specs
for this module that's missing.
What does the module do?
It does memory, you know, so touching
his head, speaking about operations.
So he's on the is on the brink
of recognizing that things were not
as he expected,
that things are in fact quite different.
That my point being that
this evokes feelings, that this is bad
this is a
this is a panic inducing situation.
And because this man has damage
to these precision modulation mechanisms
that we've been talking about, that he
what he does is he simply up regulates
the or maintains
his confidence in his prediction.
And in this way, maintains
his his emotional equanimity
rather than allowing the unpleasant
affect to dominate and the unpleasant,
unpleasant affect to update
to to
doing to to upregulated every signal
and and which would which would normally
update the predictive model.
So I'm hoping that in this case,
you can see something of the role
of affect the role that the
the feelings involved in this man's case
in relation to his predictions
and the prediction errors.
In other words, the cognitive business
of what he perceives
and what he believes
and how what he perceives
changes what he believes
and the role of feeling in all of this
I thought this was a succinct case
to be able to illustrate
and illustrate all of that.
The because it's only
one case, I thought I should just
show you some of this.
These are the several papers
that we've written on showing how
these mechanisms work in confabulation.
We it's not just this one case
we were able to show that affect
regulation.
That's that the Confabulate confabulation
has a wistful quality.
In other words, it has a down
regulating of error signals quality
and an up
regulating of predictions quality
and we were we were also able to show
that by analysis
of transcripts of cases like this,
we studied many cases like this
how the effect actually improves
with each confabulation.
So there's an increasing negative ethic
followed by confabulation,
followed by an improvement in the affect.
So I see I'm right at the end of my time.
I just want to
I don't have time to go into this point.
I'm sorry.
And this is
this is not such a fundamental point.
It's just a slightly different way
that I see the predictive
hierarchy if we if we
take seriously
that what we are talking about here,
fundamentally we
we are talking about homeostatic systems
and that the most important predictions
have to do with maintaining your,
your phenotypic prior preference
distribution, that this has implications
for how we conceptualize
the predictive hierarchy.
But as I say,
we don't have time to go into that
and then the last thing is just to say
that these models that we, that I've,
I've together with my colleagues
derived from the study
of of the neuroscientific evidence
on the basis of this well known
statement of of Richard Feynman's
what I can't create, I do not understand
we, we are trying to instantiate
these mechanisms that I described to you
earlier in an artificial consciousness.
I'm working with a group
of really great guys
and physicists and,
and computer scientists
and applied mathematicians
and we presented our preliminary findings
a few months ago
at a college, for instance,
theoretical neurobiology meetings.
And so watch this space we are we are
we are saying that
if we have identified the mechanism,
the causal mechanism where
whereby ethics are generated,
what they actually do
in relation to a self-organizing system,
then if this really is
how ethics is is generated,
if this really is how it is caused,
then we should be able to instantiated
in a, in an artificial system.
And that's what we
what we are trying to do at the moment.
I'm sorry to have rushed at the end,
but if you'll indulge me, I will wait for
if there are any questions, comments,
I just want to reassure you.
So this is I'm saying these questions
can be that they look quite different
if we look at it through the lens
that I've tried to encourage you
to look at it with me through in
other words, through the lens of affect
these questions why and how is this
something it's like to be an organism,
something it's like for the organism
and questions like
why is the performance of these functions
accompanied by experience?
This is Thomas's this question
Why doesn't all this information
process
God in the dock free of any in the field?
I'm saying that these questions
I've tried to provide you a clue
as to how we might be able
to address them differently.
Ooh, what happened there?
I've lost my
or my good. OK.
Oh, there I am. Yes.
How we might be able
to address them differently,
but get them through this lens.
Sorry to have gone on my word.
I can't believe I've spoken
for 2 hours again,
but if you, if you will,
I'll be happy to wait for any further
comments and questions before we end
us as we have actually
a whole document of questions
and many questions in the chat.
I think it's a perfect place
to end the live session.
And whenever the Affordance presents
itself, we're always happy
to have a dart three
the numbers keep counting
and we'll keep hosting the sessions
because this was very fascinating
and I hope people got a lot out
of it and very tantalizing
thank you so much for inviting me
and apologies
for going on for so long,
and I really enjoyed
what little interchange
we had over these 4 hours.
I really enjoy it. Thank you so much.
Maybe one nice future
event
could be picking up on those last two,
which are extremely interesting
and important,
and then starting with those two
with the dot one and the dot two
as prerequisite
and then sharing more about those two
when the time is right and having that
as more of a full discussion.
Very good thank you, Mark.
Thank you, Steve. Dave.
Thanks, Stephen.
Thanks, Dave. Thanks, Daniel.
He saw something else.
Take a bite.
All right.
Thanks, everybody, for watching.
Hope you enjoyed that. See you later.